[Applause]
Hardaway gives it back to da judge seven
on the shot clock against Beiber's blows
by him and kicks it out to curry
Money Ball nine point nine to play Mele
got it to fall
was it on the line was it a three or was
it a to the three-pointer look at the
concentration required that is seven
foot three an absolutely perfect
defensive position watch his left hand
go up to challenge this shot are you
kidding me Miko Mellie who struggle
shooter shoot Niko favor screen matched
up against Hardaway jr. tough shot by
Ingram he's made a couple of those
tonight's tipped up and in by Derrick
Favors 13th offensive rebounds blocks
enough yes did you afraid to get on that
bus gets the layup that thing has been
at the top of the offensive standings
all year Dallas holiday great hook
Batson find two favors for the punch
Carlisle made the fall from the
sidelines post up porzingis ada look
easy over rico belly
[Applause]
John Wilson Williamson a PI over cleaver
sensor mama sets a month by making them
think I'm gonna try to go baseline and
it spins back she gets a switch baver
step back three by Luca need to stop
here straight pocket pass and a punch
hole
their chest JP
or point maverick leads through holiday
with the left in a return slam
[Applause]
pelicans need a little bit of a miracle
here Williamson goes quick with it and
gets the layup I've said how brilliant
Maxie clima has been all night